Hello,
we are live.
I had some client stuff to deliver
today, so I'm on a bit late. Very late,
in fact.
I'm trying to think what we should do
today because I've only got, you know,
about two and a half hours. I have to
get some stuff done and today is also
deadlift day.
I get some time in that. Hello. Hi from
Chino. Welcome, Kimo.
Me switch the screen over.
I don't know what's been up with um
X lately, but
we are at 24K, which is pretty cool.
So, we still have um
many things to do left on on Puffer 4.
I'm trying to think if I want to do the
VEC back end right now, if that's the
best idea.
uh we either work on like supporting all
the different games at the same time.
Uh or we work on
Yeah. vectorization or we work on the
Perf.
I think the only thing that makes sense
to me is
is the vectorzation. I'm just trying to
think how bad that's going to be
If I just want to multi-thread it, I
think it's not bad at all. The buffering
and loading and stuff I think is harder.
What if we just try to get it
multi-threaded today and nothing else?
I think that's like a reasonably sized
task.
Uh, but I kind of want to plan this out
with respect to the rest of the week.
So, tomorrow is going to be I've got
tomorrow and I've got um Oh, is today
Wednesday or Thursday?
Date of today. It is Wednesday.
Okay.
Uh, so then I have Thursday and Friday.
So, let me think. Cuz I kind of tend to
plan things around leaving a big chunk
of work for Saturday, but having it try
to be like one type of big chunk of
work.
If I could by the end of the day
Saturday, have what done? Would I be
happy?
If I could have puffer lib
multi-threaded,
not double buffered,
stable on multiple environments.
I think that would be ideal. I think I'd
be happy with that, right?
I think I can do more than that as well.
Let's also throw in because once stable
then I can do perf optim, right? Let's
throw in perf optim with that as well
for Saturday.
Yeah. So I think then today we'll just
do multi-threading.
Today we'll do multi-threading.
Oops. I need to go look at this PR.
We have a PR for it as well that I can
look at.
Okay, I think then the best thing for me
to do is we're going to we'll start
porting this in. Let me get my first
deadlift set in for today because I'm on
late. I need to get three sets in today.
Uh, so let's do that and then I will
start working on
I think we're just going to see if I can
split up the M's across multiple threads
and that's it
and then sync. Yeah, just so we have
like some basic back end in and then
from there it'll be easier to do the
fancier one.
Oh yeah, actually that's probably not
that bad at all. That's like probably
pretty easy. Okay, I'll be back.
Five is not happening today. We will uh
we'll settle for four. Whoops. Let me
wash this chalk off.
It's a member only gem. They send out
invitations on gold leaf. If you're a
jacked scientist,
[snorts]
that shit's heavy.
I'm like super weak last few days. I've
just been doing too much work. I've had
like extra client stuff to do in the
evenings the last several days. I really
just have not gotten much time to relax
at all. It's basically just been
constant constant work and that means
worse sleep and worse recovery. So,
the exercise has taken about a I'm going
to say 15% effort hit.
Still, that's
three.
Yeah, 375 for four. Wanted to get three
sets of five in today, but we'll settle
for three to four sets of four.
You got to remember like there's all
sorts of stuff even that's pretty basic
that I just haven't done because like so
much Python.
Hey, for real.
Okay, so they just have an atomic
variable. I didn't realize that C just
has that.
That's like cool.
Cool. See, very cool.
If you're not a bot type puffer fish in
the chat, Rosie.
quick BG?
Oh, I had worker cues and stuff was too
complicated.
Comic int
voided locks. Yeah, we don't need
complicated crap.
Where's this thing get created? So, this
is C thread step.
Okay, here it is.
You just added this here.
Hey, Jen. Welcome.
Very beautiful drone rewrite is inbound
shortly. Oh, well, thank you.
That sounds fun. Hey, Sam. Long time no
see.
And that is a bot.
We get rid of the bot.
I know it seems like a bot conversation.
Doesn't type puffer fish. Literally
anticipates. Is that a bot?
Hello, Finn. Simil getting there as
well. I'm glad that there's progress.
It'll be cool. And of course, you'll
have Puffer 4 to play with by uh by
summer, if not puffer five by then.
Puffer four, puffer five. May, February,
March, April, May. You might have puffer
five by then. And we'll see.
I'm trying for six month release cycle,
man. I'm kicking my ass doing this. I'm
literally on a farm in the middle of
nowhere and I've still managed to work
so much I've burnt myself out pretty
bad.
I'm going to take some extra time off.
Um,
well, realistically, I have no idea
when.
Maybe I'll do maybe
well Sunday. Yeah, maybe I'll take
Monday. We'll see. Depends how uh how
things are going.
I want the updates to be like I don't
want them to be updates to Puffer Lib,
right? I want the updates the major
version updates to Puffer Lib to be
updates to the field of RL.
So, if I can crank two of those a year,
I'm pretty happy. [laughter]
Uh, any stupid idea in SF that like the
VCs are currently on about. I don't
know.
Unicorns are kind of lame.
Wait. Eval forward. LSTM plus step
inside C.
Wait.
Most of evaluate.
Are you doing the network itself in C?
Like the torchnet
Oh well, yeah, that's what I'm doing
already. Peru,
that's impuffer for
It's just this.
You put the obs on the device, you call
forward, you sample some logs,
and here you're vex stepping your end in
C++.
Uh if you have something that integrates
with Jess's work to like if you have
something that's like clean and
integrates for testing that would be
nice. I don't know what Jess is doing
for uh benchmarks.
Might just be using Stockfish directly.
I don't know.
D vex step directly.
Well, there is not. Uh yeah, that's
where it will be.
What are you charging an hour as a dev?
I don't charge per hour, Jen. I charge
per project.
How's gym going?
Uh, four reps of 375 about I don't know
20 minutes ago. 15 20 minutes ago.
It's going all right enough.
Been pretty tired this week. I've had a
lot of work to do.
Oh, you discord working on the L. Yeah,
we are cool.
Just P thread T.
This for now.
Okay, I have to understand what the heck
this is all doing
Why do you do like this? Can't I just do
dot?
Oh, it needs an address, doesn't it? Oh,
wait.
Wake up. You have some work story of my
life.
No new line curly bracers
allowed
Okay. So this is initialize some
threads. Yes.
How are you doing? What am I doing
today? I was uh busy doing some client
work earlier and now I'm working on
integrating peruse vector uh thread back
end into PRC.
Trying to think if there's any cool
stuff. I mean, I guess I technically do
have some cool stuff to post, but I
guess you'll get the early preview of
it.
Um,
yeah. So, this is Mingru
and then this is single GPU Mingru which
is super slow, but even the multiGP one
with no retuning of hypers, exact same
number of parameters, it seems to be
matching or doing a little bit better so
far. This is still going to take like
another couple days to run, but um you
know, if this thing matches or beats
this, then we're basically completely
confident that the new architecture is
solid, which is awesome.
Steps.
Uh yeah, this is just like a a you know
small number like a 650 billion steps or
something observations. No biggie.
MMO 3. The big end.
The big gun,
you know.
How long does it take? It depends
because we've actually gotten it to be
quicker now. But like the normal old
baseline was 5 billion steps for it to
start learning anything.
Okay, I have to understand what this
thing is doing.
I probably need to go get my um coffee
as well.
signals all threads to wake up
starting naturally.
variable work index signals all threads
to wake up.
Is each end handling one? It looks like
each thread is handling one step,
I'm in middle of a league game.
[laughter]
Another benefit of Linux is you can't
download League.
I'm confused as to how
is this running in the thread
C thread step.
I'm confused because this is C thread
step here.
So I don't understand how this works
because c vexep is called from the main
thread. But I see right here
it looks like it's calling cep
repeatedly, right? Which should be the
blocking call.
Shouldn't the
Wait,
but your number of threads aren't tied
to your number of cores.
Shouldn't they get moved on to the right
cores anyways?
cuz I think the main threat is going to
have something else to do.
Let me see. Then where did you put
then? Wait, where the heck are the rest
of these things getting?
Wait, why do you have you have a mutex
and you have busy waiting?
Okay, cool. I saw this and I thought it
was busy waiting. That's fine.
The multipprocessing implementation in
Python has to busy wait, funny enough.
that like the terrible like trash
library?
Once all threads are woken up, they busy
loop without waiting.
just a single work index.
But aren't they all fighting over that
freaking index, dude?
This that's not a mutex though, right?
That's a condition variable. Hang on.
What's the type of that thing?
Platform atomic int. Got it.
Try something.
We have 16
redsing.
This stuff actually matters, believe it
or not.
Yeah, this is what I thought.
So I think your Peru I think your
implementation is almost good. Um I
think that the one thing that's missing
I think that you need to have it go over
it needs to dec it needs to decrement by
more than one.
So each time a thread acquires,
it needs to be able to grab more than
one environment instance
because like you don't want to have
basically this should be a noop, right?
This is basically a noop.
Like I don't want a noop to already be
in the 30 to 100 million like step per
second range, right?
Like this is actually already slower
than uh singlethreaded pong for
instance.
Well, it's very close. I think I think
it's just that you want to be able to
assign larger chunks of work at a time.
Uh this is way way better than in Python
because in Python the overhead is just
so stupidly high that you can't even
really do this. But I think that I think
you can do this in C. You just have to
give slightly larger blocks of work.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is this is very close.
This is very close indeed.
How on earth would it be?
How on earth would it be close to X++?
That's going to be billions.
Why is this a void star as well?
Oh, it has to be. It probably has to be.
Yeah, there's got to be a better way to
do this, right?
That'll spin an entire core. Peru,
right? That'll just steal a full core.
Yeah, but that's a really dumb patch
cuz I'm going to want to do other stuff
with that thread, man. Like what's going
to actually happen is when I double
buffer this thing, that thread is going
to be responsible for detecting when a
chunk of M's are done and uh for like
calling
CUDA on that data basically.
Yeah, this is going in Puffer 4, Jess
right now. That's what I'm doing.
I promised him it would go in and that
it was just going to take me a while to
get to it. And so, here you go. Right.
I was going to have to do it anyways.
and he saved me a bunch of time.
Jess, I don't want to ship it until we
get 10 mil.
I know what needs to be done at this
point. It's mostly a matter of like it's
just a ton of work
and I need to balance it better.
lighting looks softer today. Uh
yeah, it's the autofocus because it's
like super cloudy out and overcast
today.
I am sitting directly, this is probably
not the best spot for a camera. I'm
directly in front of a like 4x6 ft
window.
So,
and then I have another one there and
another one there and another one there.
I'm pretty much surrounded by 4x6 foot
windows. [sighs]
Two sides at least. They're not
surrounded at all, but whatever.
Welcome to America
is a good country, sir.
Oh yeah, there are quite a few people on
YouTube now. Hello everybody. Uh I have
not done threading in native C before.
I've done a heck of a lot of
multipprocessing and optimization in
Python, which is basically the same as C
but harder. Uh
So I'm currently attempting to figure
this out based on a thing that Peru
wrote and I'm making some small
modifications.
Uh the goal is to have very high
throughput and simple vectorization. So
multi-threading backend for all of our
reinforcement learning MS.
And I'm also stalling because I got to
do my second deadlift set and I'm
exhausted. So
LM friend binding. Nope.
Oh, is the wait is LLM friend finding
this? This is me doing fuzzy docks
basically just trying to figure out how
to use mutexes.
Yeah, for real.
I guess this is not bad though cuz this
only happens at the end, right?
When and why do we use and need RLMs in
the real world?
So at the moment there are like a few
areas where they're used. Uh robotics is
the very obvious one. There's some
logistics and then there like some
random problems, data center cooling,
there's like logistics.
Um there's stuff in finance. So it's
like spread around. Uh but within a
couple of years, right, if I continue to
work on this and I make RL as good as I
think I will have it, uh then pretty
much anywhere you use simulators,
not exactly everywhere, but a lot of the
places that you use simulators in the
real world, um because you just make
simulation a way, way more powerful tool
in general with RL because you unlock
intelligent simulation basically instead
of saying like, hey, I'm gonna run a sim
to see what happens. you get to say,
"Hey, I'm going to run a sim to see how
I can get to an objective that I care
about." So, I say, "This is what I want
to have happen in the sim." And the RL
figures out how to do it.
So, very, very powerful toolkit.
And it's very funny because like you
know we use games a lot in research but
then like every single time I'll just
take the algorithm that I've developed
by training on various different games
and it'll just crush all sorts of real
world applications out of the box. Like
yeah games are just harder than your
trading environment or like your
whatever the heck uh your control
environment or logistics. We've done a
whole bunch of stuff lately
and yeah, games are just harder.
So, it turns out the games are very
useful.
And I think I like this as the basis.
Um, I'm going to have to actually make
this work.
Anish I have if you seen my uh I don't
know if you're new here if you've seen
my thesis though.
Oops.
Yeah. Okay. Here's a 170 page PhD thesis
in which I spent like
five years of PhD plus two years before
that building MMO inspired environments
and doing tons and tons of engineering
and research on how do we make this
stuff work.
Yeah.
So, pretty much exactly that.
Let me get my deadlift set in. I got to
do it at some point. And I got two more,
so I may as well get started.
to AI by playing games.
Mate, you're Iron Man. Not yet.
[laughter]
Not yet. Soon.
I also do some pretty decent endurance
running.
Yeah, pretty much all of the soda
reinforcement learning came from games
as well.
This is kind of funny part.
Okay, so let's see if we can actually
I actually feel more awake from that
already. Um, let's see if I can get this
thing to run.
Compile first and then run.
average pulse rate.
Well, it's going to be [ __ ] now, I'm
sure, after that. But it's not great,
but it's genetic.
Or maybe it's not genetic, honestly. It
might just be stress. Who the hell
knows?
It was low 70s last I checked and before
I started running. So when I could
deadlift four plates, but before I
started running, I had like 83 resting.
Thank
Yeah, it just goes to like 80.
Um,
minimum in the last
12 hours.
Yeah, that's kind of not great
considering that includes sleeping is
minimum 76.
57. Yeah, good for you. I run I run um
you know, five days a week.
Heck, even when I was doing like 45
miles a week, the lowest it would ever
get would be like low 70s
No man, I did I did all of my like not
sleeping for a lifetime when I was
younger. Now I sleep
best I can.
Yeah, it's it's terrible, man.
I didn't do undergrad at MIT, though. I
did MIT grad. I did Stanford undergrad.
I think I worked like 90 hour weeks
maybe my freshman year, but then I
didn't do I didn't think I did 90 most
of the time after that.
I think I had like 80ish maybe for the
first chunk of my sophomore year and I
think it was like mostly 70 after that.
Thickness cardiac
volume, average stroke volume.
Well, I mean, what am I supposed to do?
So, I've run in the last couple of
years, uh, I've run two marathons in a
50k. I've probably logged like over
2,000 miles of training at this point.
Um, I do a bunch of powerlifting, some
bodybuilding, uh, bodybuilder style
training. Uh, I've been doing like a
bunch of dedicated flexibility work
lately. I got a pretty damn good diet,
doing pretty much everything I can do on
that front.
But of course, I also have the
self-imposed mantra of trying to solo a
scientific field. So,
no pressure.
How do I get Popper to compile an end
with which is many C andH files? Well,
you're going to have to modify the uh
the setup to include them, right?
If you if you just have many.h files,
you can just you don't have to modify
the setup. If you have many C files,
you're going to have to modify the comp
the compile command.
There's a reason that we don't split
stuff up, Sam.
Wait, the I hope the drone refactor is
not splitting it into a million files.
Is that the 20s?
Uh, that was not the super grind onish.
That was the um like actually kind of
reasonable amount of work. The super
grind was getting to undergrad in which
I worked probably average of 110 hours a
week from ages
15 or 16 to 18.
[sighs]
So actually undergrad was like not that
much work by comparison afterwards.
Where do I find the compile commands in
pure C? It's scripts build ocean. Um,
and for the uh Python one, it's the
setup.py. And you're not going to find
the like the full compile command. You
just have to add the like extra C source
files and the build extensions because
it just is com it's looking for one C
file that matches the name of your
environment. So, you'd have to add them
there.
Uh though yeah, those are not they're no
entrance exams. Roger. That's not how it
works. That would be a lot easier in
some sense because then you just know if
you get the score on the test, you're
good.
Instead, it's just the uh you know the
Illuminati there saying
amuse us with your efforts and maybe we
will allow you to attend a university
where education is not complete and
other [ __ ] and is only complete and
utter [ __ ] about twothirds of the time.
separated rendering and tasks.
Okay, cool. Combine the two M's back
into one. That is acceptable cuz we
already had like the drone lib thing.
That is good.
Two files is allowed. Uh, but you know,
Sam, if you want to avoid compiler
headaches, just like make the file that
they both use, just make it ah, just put
the stuff in ah and then you can just
include it directly
and not have to deal with like you don't
have to mess with the compile commands
that way. It'll be way better.
Hierarchical RL doesn't work.
Deep mind and open AI. Open AI didn't
really try honestly. It was mostly deep
mind getting nerd sniped. There may be a
couple ideas in there that have some
merit, but I would say that it was
generally like not super promising.
Percent of Ivy grads had family members
attend as well. Uh,
nobody in my direct ancestry, I don't
think.
No, nobody in my direct ancestry.
As far as the academics go, I have that
I have that basis covered.
I mean, not to say I wasn't prepped like
hell, but I put in the work.
Actually, one of the most depressing
things was like getting to Stamford and
realizing that like the vast majority of
the people there had just gotten lucky
and had not put in any work and were
actually incredibly stupid and
unmotivated.
Oh, I took some MBA classes while I was
at MIT. Holy hell. You want to talk
about a bunch of morons?
No, thank you. I think I will go back to
the
uh the lazy and unmotivated
uh STEM people at the very least.
modelbased RL is the better version of
hierarchical RL. Okay, if you think
about that for literally 5 seconds, like
you'll notice it makes absolutely no
sense. Dude,
please go ahead and think about that for
literally 5 seconds. And if you still
think it makes sense, please explain to
me why you like why that sentence should
exist.
all I need here is then
we call create environments with threads
now.
So we call create environments with
threads
and that's it I think.
Well, I mean, I don't know. The thing on
is like
I mostly care about people who are like
smart enough to actually get stuff done
and motivated enough to actually want to
try to aim high and like actually
continuously put in the work.
Um,
like the favorite my favorite people in
the field are mostly not from like
similar backgrounds to myself and
they're a bunch of people from like
random places for the most part
who just like actually gave a [ __ ] and
did something out of left field.
Of course, you know, I was like that for
a while in my younger years and I didn't
have the talent to back it up, but you
do that for enough years and you get the
talent to back it up.
It's your own not just searching for
long-term horizons. Instead of building
actions, it's building worlds.
model based RL not just searching for
long-term horizons.
I'll believe the modelbased RL stuff
when somebody produces like a version of
it that is not just complete [ __ ]
Until then, it's just like a nerd snipe
idea.
model based RL is doing supervised next
state or next latent or next frame
prediction
and then doing RL on the rollouts of
those hallucinated next states.
So it is doing next state prediction and
then doing perfectly on policy RL on
those hallucinated next states or obs or
whatever depending on the version.
This not standard atomic.
I have standard atomic, don't I?
Yeah, but like model based RL is the
super trendy thing.
Trendy things don't actually have to
work.
Okay, this is literally the only error
left somehow.
object-oriented
functional programming. What paradigm
would one should one start with? Write
the code as simply as possible in one
file top to bottom without attempting to
like do stuff in adherence to a specific
ideology.
For simple environments, modelbased RL
makes no sense. Things like autonomous
driving, it makes a lot of sense.
Okay, this is the best open-source
autonomous driving sim available.
We did this uh this port in partnership
with NYU. Multiple companies are using
it. It trains at I think latest is like
800,000 steps per second on one GPU.
Good luck doing that with modelbased RL.
create a world model. Yeah, good luck
with that.
I actually think that particular version
makes no sense
because you're essentially if you're
going to use that model to do RL and
you're not actually like if you're going
to do model based RL the version of it
that makes sense is at least having a
simulator in the loop. If you're going
to just go collect a big data set to
build a world model then you are
literally just like training uh you're
just training your agent to poke holes
in it.
basic MLP bra. No.
What
object-oriented programming to
understand back prop?
No.
Okay. If that's the case, then how the
heck am I writing back prop in CUDA?
Like what?
No.
Thunder functions. Those don't even ex
That's a Python thing. Those don't even
exist.
You can go write yourself an autograd in
C in like the same amount of code it
would be in Python with just like
functions and strrus.
Honest actually from that statement you
should absolutely start writing some C
environments. You will see your entire
view of programming change immediately
to something that is much more
enjoyable.
It's weird though because this is I'm
compiling this as a CDL.
yeah, my guy, you need to just like
start writing here. This doesn't have a
backward pass, but I could easily add a
backward pass to this. All right, this
is basically torch.
Not really. It's super unoptimized, but
look, these are just functions that
define the forward passes of stuff. All
right, and you can just call the forward
function and call the backward function.
simpler to use the available data. Okay,
but like what do you do with that world
model? You do nothing.
You're going to RL the world model. So,
you're just going to poke holes in it.
You can't actually you don't actually
train a policy out of that.
You don't have to hardcode all the
scenarios. Like you can just put some
cars in maps and have them drive around
a bunch. And most of the edge cases are
emergent
like this is working now and we get good
policies on one GPU
and again actual driving companies are
using this
and yes it is not it's like it's way
more simplified than It could be. But
the am the point is that the amount of
data this saves you, right? The amount
of like real world data that you don't
have to have because you have this is
massive.
My brain implementing
basic micro and C.
Honestly, Anish, don't try to do
autograd. Just implement the forward and
the backward and then don't think about
the graph stuff.
It shouldn't be defined in the files. I
don't know what I did.
It's not here. Like the thing I don't
understand. So this is getting compiled
as a DLL. Okay. This is a CDL
and it should be included from this. And
then like when I compile this,
so this includes that end. So this
should have this should have access to
atomic int. And then when I compile
this, this works fine. But then when I
compile the torch extension,
actually what? Hang on. Maybe this is
getting included by mistake.
All nighters freshman college. Oh man, I
did so so so many of those.
I remember that the uh I missed lunch
with Andrew Ing because I was doing some
stuff around his lab and he said, "Oh
yeah, I'm going to have lunch with the
people in my lab uh today." But he like
he sent the message in like early in the
morning or something and I was just
asleep until the afternoon because I'd
been up till 4:00 a.m. working on
research.
Well, this gets included here, right?
Because this needs this death.
Uh, well, I did get my first paper out
of it, so probably
Yeah, I need to just figure out what is
the um
what's the name of the the type that I
can use?
Comic load.
Oh, I see.
I hate C++.
I hate C++ so much.
I don't get any metrics back though,
which is probably bad.
Tesla. Yeah, so Tesla has unlimited
freaking data already. I don't know how
they use it. Um,
I don't know if they're doing world
model stuff, man, or if they're just
doing straight like Iel
Uh, it's great if you want to write a
depression simulator on ish
world record speed run depression any%.
Right.
Let's figure out why this thing is um
So, hype. Um, the reason I'm so negative
on world models is because I've done
pretty extensive work on the dreamer
line and it's like [ __ ] It's total
[ __ ] It doesn't remotely work as
presented or for the reasons presented.
But like basically the main piece of
evidence behind this whole line is just
like absolutely horrible science
and I've already spent like hundreds of
hours figuring that out. So yeah, I get
annoyed with them. It's like, oh yeah,
look, we could just use world models for
everything. When I know based on
research that like they're nowhere near
uh as presented normally, right?
So essentially they go back from being
like this like oh super amazing thing to
just like a clever sounding idea that
maybe works maybe doesn't
but it's certainly not the second coming
of Christ or anything.
Certain old Frenchmen.
Certain old. What?
Why is you care so much
the idea of world models altogether?
Uh it's basically based on if you just
take the how they are in the literature
and then you know what I know about them
actually not working that well. Uh, it
basically takes it back from
like these are good to I don't actually
know whether the premise of this makes
any bloody sense and I sure as well am
not going to like predicate my research
on this odd direction that doesn't even
seem like it's obviously a good idea
when I have this other thing that I can
work on that I know for sure is going to
work. I know for sure is going to scale
and I know for sure I can make it
another 10x better than it is now.
And in the high data regime, I think my
approach is fundamentally better. So
yeah, we'll see.
The thing I don't know about world
models is like you basically set up like
a GAN type thing, right? Where you're
trying to train a world model and your
RL agent is trying to poke holes in your
world model. Like if you have a perfect
world model, it makes sense. Sure. But
it seems like you literally set it up to
have compounding errors in the world
model.
How did Mingru do on Neural MMO 3?
Go check.
This is the 6GPU run that is fast but a
little less sample efficient. This is
the one GPU run that is slow uh and a
little more sample efficient. They're
both currently still above the uh puffer
30 LSTM baseline.
I think I probably just didn't integrate
this correctly from um
Peru because it doesn't make sense to me
the way it looks.
You see how he did it?
Why do you need threads in this
application?
Because we're running thousands of
instances of simulators and I'd like to
not run them on one core. And we have
this working in Python, but now I want
to have a native C back end.
Like when we're training when we're
training our RL agents, right? Like we
don't just run one instance of this. You
think we like you think that it plays
one game of Tetris at a time? No, we run
like 8,000 games of this in parallel and
then we run them at like 10,000 times
realtime speed as well.
It's like an unfathomable amount of
data.
Buffer very fast. Yes, Buffer Lib is the
fastest reinforcement learning library
by like more than an order of magnitude.
It's going to get even bigger next
update.
It'll be good.
I can simply figure out why.
I don't understand why he is not
setting.
Each of these does an AD
open MP.
Why would I use that?
Oh, is this MPI?
Nah, screw MPI.
Or is this different?
Why wouldn't I just use Cthreads though,
man?
Why would I like grab a library for
what's going to end up being 100 lines
of code in native C?
I can in halfway. Is this not your code?
This this is uh so Peru submitted a PR
and I he submitted a PR to the uh Python
end bindings and I'm working on taking
this and integrating it into the C
native bindings.
automatic loop scheduling across
threads. Cool. I don't want automatic
scheduling.
I want to do it manually and have like
maximum PF.
It's a very simple workload that needs
to be optimized very well.
And I still don't know why you would
ever grab like um why you would ever
grab like a third party library for
something that you can do yourself as
well or better in a 100 lines.
also got to check on
client
eths are platform specific.
You're not running like you're not doing
scientific computing on anything that's
not Linux.
college football said you won't be
streaming tomorrow. No, I I will be
streaming uh tomorrow's what? Thursday.
Yeah, I'll be streaming tomorrow.
Dude, I don't do stuff via like
No, I want to understand how this works.
Just because I'm like too tired to do
this quickly doesn't mean I'm gonna go
use a language model and then ship
something I don't understand.
Test sharing. It's literally
embarrassingly parallel. It's literally
you just have a whole bunch of
environments and then you need to run
you know different instance of them on
uh on different threads. That's it. It's
a really easy task.
It's really hard to implement this in
Python. Like so the Python vectorzation
I have is really complicated because um
every single synchronization primitive
in Python is too high overhead to use.
If you do it in C, it becomes a lot
easier. I just am not used to this is
all because I'm I never do anything with
threads because in Python threads are
useless. So I do everything with
processes. So I have to like remap a
couple things. Yeah. Yeah. writer.
Generally, we kind of do minimal like a
minimal LLM usage around here.
I pretty much use them as like fuzzy
docks and that's about it.
Work index
size minus one.
on broadcast. So, okay, we broadcast
awake
We can use this to try to find out why
it's happening though, not to rewrite
it.
Hang on.
I think that the synchronization is
correct though. looking at it.
You're not setting running threads.
Yeah, it's fine though.
Huh?
Smart LLM.
Very good job, LLM. Look at this.
I don't think you should need to do this
though,
right? Because like Yeah, this is wrong.
It's
supposed to increment here.
Numb threads. Yeah, it's supposed to
increment here.
I got dinner soon. If anybody knows, let
me know. I'm going to use the restroom
real quick and I'm going to get my last
deadlift set in and then I'll take a few
more minutes on this before dinner. And
uh I'll also discuss a few other things
that are going to go on around here.
FBR, the bot you wrote is better than
random, but it's not even beating 1320.
Stockfish
counting draw by repetition early.
Got to PR some things so your stuff gets
checked.
Otherwise, it's like what? 2,800 yellow
bot. Yeah, sure.
Now is a good time to mention for folks
because I got to go in a few minutes. Um
I don't think I'm doing an evening
stream tonight. I'm either going to do
some client work or just crash. Been a
heck of a few days. Um
but yeah, all my stuff is free. It's
open source right here. You can support
the project for absolutely free by
starting the repository to feed the
puffer. Uh, you can join the discord to
get involved with dev and you can follow
me on X for all my content, including
educational articles and more.
Gemini 31 shot everything. [ __ ]
Look, I'm I don't even try the models
anymore because like all the companies,
they just lie constantly
and then you actually try the model and
it's like the derp. I can't even make
code that compiles,
num threads less than equal zero.
Okay.
Best way to get involved is to literally
just like
if you're looking to learn RL, this is
the best place. And if you follow this
guide, you will be very capable in RL.
If you actually go through and do what
is advised here,
it has some projects for you. It links
you to like a large but very manageable
number of references. It has a lower
math requirement than any other resource
on this topic.
Does still take some work though.
And then if you're I mean for science in
general, I've got this more general
article.
I don't know. Can I just stick break
points in threaded code? Is that a thing
I can do?
Oh, but I'm going to have to do it from
freaking
C++, which is annoying.
I don't even know if that'll work
through a DL.
Yeah. No, that doesn't work through a
DL.
Well, I think that the next session I
spend on this fresh, I'm going to just
have to write a little test on it. I'll
write a test in pure C. It'll be a lot
easier.
HPC compilers and math
display. Cool enough. I mean, we mostly
build high perf Sims around here and do
RL
Okay. Well, I'm going to just go get
dinner. I'm pretty much exhausted for
today. So, I'm just going to check and
make sure the client is happy with their
deliverable from today. And then other
than that, I think I'm going to chill
for the evening and I'm going to
recharge and I'm going to come back
tomorrow and we're going to heammer out
vectorization.
When I starting